how are you good morning tell us more
about this
yeah this is a judgment from the
European Court of human rights in
Strasbourg and uh Jerry Kate McCann had
had appealed to that Court under what
stands as article eight that is their
right to family life and to privacy now
this does relate to a book documentary
newspaper interviews done by Gonzalo
morale who was a detective who was
working on the investigation Into The
Disappearance of Madeleine which was
back in 2007 when she was just three
years old now he actually retired the
following year
2008 wrote a book he's actually
subsequently wrote written a second book
in which he makes it clear that he
thinks responsibility lies with the
mccanns they clearly have been holding a
long-standing grievance against Mr
Amaral and when didn't appealed
obviously to the Portuguese courts who
who dismissed that and then appealed to
the European Court of Human Rights
saying that saying that their privacy
and their right to a family life have
been improved but that was in a sense a
legal mechanism for effectively looking
for redress appealing for libel in in
terms we would recognize
and saying that they had uh that they
had been misrepresented that their
reputation had been trashed that appeal
has now been rejected by the court we've
just received the Judgment in front of
us here it is a a long judgment
and it makes pains absolute pains to say
that the rejection of this case is not
in any way suggest any culpability any
criminal culpability should be passed in
the direction of the mccanns but what it
does say is that on this specific
allegation about privacy about the right
to a family life that the mccanns could
not legitimately claim that because of
the high-profile nature of this case
because of their proactive involvement
uh with what was clearly a very a very
high profile media coverage and to that
extent they had abrogated their sense
their right to privacy so on this very
specific area this complaint they have
lost this the knock-on effects of this
clearly in terms of the cost of this
legal proceeding to the McCann family
will now be a question for them